[موسيقى]
واشوف الصور وكده قطع الموضوع ده هو
مكالمه من
فحاولت اقدر الامكان انه خلال المسار بتاع
يعني
عيد بدون محمد فانا حاولت اغير الامكان
الوضع طبيعي
ان شاء الله يعني يومين وانا اكون
معاك يعني انا مش محظوظ يعني بحاول اطلع
[موسيقى]
غضبانه طبعا اكيد لانه انا بشوف انه في
ناس او احنا اتظلمنا يعني او بشوف انه ظلم
بالنسبه للشعب السوداني بالنسبه لانه
مقبضه محبطه طبعا لانه نحن كنا عاملين خطه
للعيد ده غير مختلفه تماما على الحاجه
اللي حصلت
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر ول
له
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منهاره انه انا ربي حلاقي اهلي ثاني ما
حلاقيهم نطلع ولا ما حنقدر نطلع لو طلعنا
نحن
هل هناك عاملين طيب اوكي لو مقابلين هناك
عاملين
بيتنا هنا وحياتنا نقدر نرجع ببيتنا
وحياتنا ويعني هنا الحياه في الخرطوم ولا
لا فدي كلها اسئله بتيجي لزول في راسه وما
لاقي لها اجوبه يعني المستقبل بالنسبه لنا
نحن حاليا
مظلم او ما عارفين ان احنا هو يعني حيكون
عامل كيف